but first it was a difficult christmas
weekend for thousands of americans
because of the latest covet surge many
travelers found themselves on epic yet
exhausting journeys after infections
among pilots crew and airline staff
caused last-minute flight changes from
friday to sunday more than 3 000 flights
were canceled across the u.s hundreds
more have already been canceled this
morning jonathan vigliotti is at lax
airport in los angeles jonathan good
morning
and good morning to you nate twice as
many people travel for christmas this
year compared to last year many people
arrived to homes impacted by covid some
people couldn't even get home
i think i felt pretty deflated i
sort of de-spirited spending christmas
eve alone in an airport hotel wasn't
what rohit tauwani had in mind for the
holidays this year
midway through my first flight got a
notification that my connecting flight
was canceled and that there were no
other flights for the day and the next
earliest flight was going to be the
following afternoon
which would mean that i was going to
miss being at home for christmas and
miss christmas eve
with my family tawani was told his
flight was canceled because of
covet-related airline crew shortages
it's frustrating that
the pandemic still keeps affecting our
lives in so many different ways even two
years out tauwani wasn't alone more than
2 thousand flights were canceled on
saturday and sunday in part due to covet
the united airlines said the nationwide
spike in omicron cases this week has had
a direct impact on our flight crews and
the people who run our operation omicron
is the grinch that stole christmas from
airline passengers henry harneveldt is a
travel industry analyst airlines can't
operate flights without the required
number of pilots and flight attendants
safety comes first
and now several airlines are calling on
the cdc to update its covet guidance for
the fully vaccinated and reduce the
quarantine isolation period from 10 days
to 5 for those who have breakthrough
cases
the government approved this request for
the health care industry and honestly if
it's good enough for hospital workers
for nurses and doctors i think it should
be good enough for the airline industry
as well
it wasn't just trouble in the skies the
cruise ship industry is also facing
covet disruptions three cruise lines had
outbreaks on board in the last week with
dozens of passengers testing positive
and forced to quarantine you had to be
fully vaccinated and you had to have a
negative test
two days before i mean what more could
they do before you
aborted the [ __ ]
a lot of frustration hartevelt says some
of the best advice for travelers
especially if you're flying is to sign
up for text alerts that way you'll be
notified immediately if there are any
disruptions to your plans to rika
text alerts and a lot of deep breathing
jonathan vigliotti thank you